secretary Carter thank you so much for
joining us it's great to answer happy
you've been very focused on rebuilding
this bridge between the Pentagon and
silicon valley you've got 16 more months
in this administration what will be
tangible proof that your outreach is
working what do you want to accomplish
in 16 a few things and I can do a lot in
16 months I'm a man in a hurry and 16
months is a long time as you know in
technology and I can start a lot even if
it'll go on as I hope it does after what
I'm gone so to get answer your question
give you some examples we're making
important investments in technology in
partnership with Silicon Valley
companies I'm going to announce a major
such initiative today in the area of
essentially flexible integrated circuits
which is a very important thing so we'll
be making investments private public
partnerships and direct investments as
we have for decades going back to the
ear of jet engines and satellite
communications right up through the
internet integrated circuits so we need
to be a technology leader to protect our
country and we can be a technology
leader only if we partner with folks out
here and the other thing is people I
need good people who are dedicated to
our mission which is protecting our
country and making a better world and
they're looking out here for interesting
problems things that are consequential
these are people who want to make a
difference in life and there's nothing
more consequential than being part of
protecting people you're a physicist by
background so you understand this stuff
what are some key technologies and
assets that you can get from Silicon
Valley that you're not getting from
current defense contractors a lot of the
really new really cutting-edge brand-new
stuff we we do get but I find that the
Defense Department over the years has
gotten a little too bureaucratic little
too slow for the pace of people out here
plus some of these people didn't grow up
as I did it in here were all of our
technology mentor
had been part of the world war 2 effort
of the cold war effort and it was kind
of in our blood to take an interest in
these things so both on the people level
some of them aren't acquainted with us
and what we do and some of our people
have never understood the VC community
or the technology community we need to
get them to understand one another and
in the technology area we have so much
to learn from the cutting edge out you
remember we don't build anything in the
Pentagon we count in this country upon
private industry and private initiative
to create the technologies that next to
the wonderful people in uniform who make
our military the finest fighting force
adair the world has ever seen next to
them technology is what made us great
and we need that too so Google for
example they've been buying a number of
robotics companies they've got a
humanoid robot a cheetah robot a dog
climbing robot when are we going to see
robot soldiers when are we going to see
self-driving cars in the field on a mass
scale I think you'll see them soon we
all already have tella operated planes
so-called drones helicopters other
things undersea vehicles true autonomy
is another step for it I just came from
a briefing by a set of advisors to me on
technology you have been studying all
summer the question of autonomy an
autonomous vehicle so you'll see them
driving underwater and doing all sorts
of things like patrolling cyber networks
to defend them all of those things will
be done autonomously or in very creative
man-machine combinations in the future
we need to be part of that revolution
much of it occurs right here and that's
another reason for my visit do you see a
future of robot armies I certainly see
robots in the field I think that it'll
be a long time before humans are
entirely removed
from conflict and also of course we're
always going to want human
decision-making and human responsibility
when it comes to the use of force what
about drones drones have been used in
the military for a long time but now you
have Amazon Facebook Google making their
own drones do you think you can learn
anything from honey sure we know a lot
but we can learn a lot also well they're
learning things about how for example to
do logistics we do a lot of logistics
that may seem mundane to you but if
you're fighting in Afghanistan or Iraq
or Syria we're getting forces and
equipment in and out is vital we're
allure nothing we learn something from
them in areas like warehousing and
inventory management which again may
sound mundane but don't forget we're
spending the taxpayers money and we're
constantly trying to do it more and more
efficiently and we learn about efficient
techniques as well as effective combat
techniques from new technology give us a
sense of the severity of the recent hack
attack on the Pentagon email system the
unclassified email system of a joint
chiefs of staff and and to what extent
has that attack prompted you to ask
Silicon Valley for help well it is a
sign to me that we're not nearly where
we need to be in terms of cyber defense
even in the Defense Department where
we've known for decades that information
technology was going to be critical or a
military edge and so we have a lot to
learn clearly our Joint Chiefs of Staff
network now it wasn't exploited in a
dangerous way and it resulted actually
from a very simple operator failure
somebody who opened an email they
shouldn't have which in all companies we
are warned against doing that so it was
fairly mundane but that's something that
mundane could affect that important a
network shows you we're not where we
need to be that shows you that we need
to be on the cutting edge of cyber
defense and this is the place where the
cutting edge of cyber defense is defined
so for if we're going to be there as we
need to be we need to do that in
partnership with Silicon Valley you
worked for secretary Gates who barely
used
as I understand it how much do you use
email and what steps have you taken to
protect your own systems well I'm sure
as long to be honest I'm very careful in
that regard and in general my staff uses
the messages and of course we send
copious messages back and forth around
the world but for myself I'm very
careful because I know that people would
like to know what you do with email if
you're a national security official and
so I'm extremely careful about it but
obviously the department remind me the
department as a whole uses email and all
kinds of other electronic aids all day
and we need to protect that because that
is necessary in order to make our forces
effective he's no point how many planes
ships and tanks if you don't have the
networks that in today's world make them
cable so when you say careful you mean
keep it short you don't send them that
often I did both of those now of course
I that's funny for me because in my
former life including when I lived out
here in Silicon Valley last year I was
on email all the time but I now in this
job I use a different way of operating
now how much have the revelations of
Edward Snowden you know degraded this
relationship between the government in
Silicon Valley and how much do you feel
you have to mend the fence well I do I
think that's another reason to build
bridges rebuild bridges that the
relationship between the technology
community and the government has had its
ups and downs over the years and the
Snowden revelations were raised two very
important issues the issue of the
balance between privacy and national
security that's a serious matter and we
can only resolve that in dialogue
between those who know a lot about that
subject and have a stake in it who are
out here and those responsible for
protecting people who are in Washington
so this bridge is important to resolving
that issue another thing that Snowden
did was was cause harm to our company's
American companies
because the others use those Snowden
revelations against our companies and
say well you can't trust them because
they're mirror you might the Chinese and
the Russians do essentially unlimited
surveillance and restriction of the
Internet in their own countries so mark
zuckerberg for example is called us
surveillance a threat to the internet
Tim Cook has said he doesn't want to
have these users have to choose between
security and privacy what do you want
from a Mark Zuckerberg what do you want
from Tim Cook well I think then with
them a hundred percent we're trying to
find a solution here that allows
ordinary people and good people
everywhere and companies everywhere to
make use of this new technology in a way
that is good for humankind and at the
same time we do need to protect
ourselves against terrorists against
pornographers criminal networks drug
runners and on and on and so there has
to be a certain amount of public order
as well as private freedom that balance
I don't think we can strike in
Washington I think we can only strike it
by talking to the greatest leaders and
minds in this field and they're out
there so that's one of the reasons I'm
here you're working on the 2017 budget
this is the last budget you're going to
have a big impact on you know we've
talked about cybersecurity be a big
problem what needs more money what needs
less money should there be a
cybersecurity arm of the military shot
cyber we cyber does need more money we
will provide new money so even in an era
when there's a lot of budget turmoil
which is terrible thing all other
subject in Washington we need to invest
more in cyber we will I don't know I do
we do that you know interestingly the
tricky thing is in cyber investments as
as any company I out here I'll bet you
will tell you isn't so much the money
it's the people we need it's finding
good people
challenging for us as we try to do cyber
defense and so hiring those people
training them deciding what mix of
uniform people government people
industry people we should have in our
cyber force that's more a more
challenging even than the dollars so a
cybersecurity arm for the military there
is a cybersecurity yarn for the military
we have a Cyber Command we have the
National Security Agency which reports
to me and so we have plenty of people
doing this but as the example you gave
earlier of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
Network shows we're not perfect we're a
long way from being perfect we need to
get better secretary Carter thank you so
much for joining remember Calvin